we actually found this clip of you on
celebrity jeopardy where I don't know
how old you are here this something
seems like it's quite a while ago you
know how old you were at the time
yeah I'm 16 and I'm 16 but I love your
enthusiasm check this out and Caulfield
the hero of this Salinger novels gates
movies phonies and his classmate earnest
Mauro Joey what is get you're in the
ride
[Applause]
was he thinks our cassock good for you
like a book that's great I gotta get
back to Canada how long I've been doing
this show I'm bitter bitter I tell you
the nicest guy he's a nice guy in the
world but you just said he's drunk and
that's gonna get around let's talk about
hit record on TV yes please it is unlike
any show and you I do sort of believe
having watched a bunch of these that
this is sort of the way a lot of
entertainment variety shows are gonna be
drifting yeah thanks because you're
using the medium you're using people
that are out there to contribute their
creativity their music their art and
make something new that's just it yeah I
mean cuz Hollywood can be sort of an
exclusive industry you know I mean
there's lots of talented people all over
the world who aren't living here don't
have an agent etc but that doesn't mean
they don't have a great perspective or a
lot of talent and so you know hit record
is the way we use the Internet and
anybody can contribute to our projects
and we make this TV show out of all the
different stuff that we make together on
the site and so you have to set up the
framework though right you have to put
something out there and then allow
people to contribute to it is that
correct yeah there's projects starting
all the time and I direct it and so I
use directors that I've worked for in
traditional movie sets as sort of the
model where we know what the director
says goes but a good director is a
collaborator and and you know is all
about encouraging the other people that
that he or she works with right to bring
out the best in them so that's sort of
the the approach I try to go forward we
have a clip here from hit record on TV
just help explain what this is we're
about to see what did it start as and
then you've got a lot of people to
contribute to it quite fascinating
thank you it started as a song that the
songwriter wrote and then and it's sort
of a funny dark song about dying right
and so we try to get people to act out
dying in funny ways and then when we put
all that video together then we had
animators from all over paint over that
footage so this is the kind of thing
where if one animator had to do it it
would have taken them a year it would
have taken so much work but because
there's lots of people all working on it
together we could do it in the amount of
time
took to make it you know for our show
what's the signal goes clip from hit
record on TV
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah those all hand-painted I'll
hand penny well the season one box set
of hit record on TV is available now and
it's fascinating you should check it out
Joseph Gordon let all ways a pleasure
great having you here
you